that's right it's time once again to
activate the famedron 6000 our patented
machine that definitely wasn't developed
in affiliation with Dr wondertainment we
swear after recalibrating rebooting and
hitting restart our Infamous specialized
supercomputer is ready to bring you all
manner of improbable scenarios we'll
simulate encounters between the SCP
foundation's various anomalies and any
other character from any other Universe
you could possibly imagine here's a
question for you what do you think would
happen if scp-096 the notorious shy guy
ran afoul of someone he couldn't just
kill for daring to look at it what if
the scourge of the underworld battler of
demons and the Devil Himself set his
sights on
scp-096 well we're about to hit the
button and discover the outcome of
scp-096 versus the dreaded Doom Slayer
so you've heard the old philosophical
debate about a tree falling down in the
woods and whether or not nobody being
around to hear it brings into question
if it actually happened at all right
well let's reframe that one a little if
an interdimensional rip in the very
fabric of the time space continuum opens
up in an SCP Foundation secure facility
and nobody is around to witness it does
a six foot tall 360 pound hulking
killing machine still emerge to
slaughter everything in his path it
turns out yes yes he definitely does
horrified screens and the loud bang of
shotgun blasts rang out through the
hallway as Foundation researchers ran
for their lives the Doom Marine had just
been unceremoniously dropped out of a
portal into a strange and unfamiliar
environment mere minutes earlier he had
been awakened inside a sarcophagus
within a facility on Mars in the year
2148. unfortunately doomguy hadn't had
the best start to his day given that the
base he'd woken up in was being overrun
by the forces of Hell itself thanks to a
rogue scientists opening up portals to
the underworld and allowing all manner
of demonic Abominations to come pouring
through so naturally when another portal
brought the armor-clad Demon's Lair to a
site run by the SCP Foundation the
intensity of battle had led to the
doomslayer believing that the
unsuspecting staff were actually all
demons in Disguise and to him the only
good Demon is one he got to send back to
hell in the most brutal fashion
imaginable he wasn't going to stop until
he'd torn through wave after wave a
foundation Personnel thinking perhaps if
he killed enough he'd be returned to his
previous Locale for more demon killing
as the foundation dispatches its
security forces and mobile task forces
to take down the Unstoppable force of
Carnage decked out in head to toe green
armor it seemed nothing they could throw
at the Doom Marine was enough to take
him down a hail of bullets rained down
on him from the mtf's weapons
ricocheting ineffectually off his
protective plating as he continued his
assault remaining tireless thanks to his
immense physical conditioning the SCP
Foundation tried and failed to contain
doomguy they assumed him to either be a
new undocumented anomaly or a violent
and unhinged Maniac from the church of
the broken God given his armor
resembling cybernetic augmentations and
machine parts grafted to his body along
with his arsenal of advanced Weaponry
but there were no enhancements no
augmentations made to the Doom Slayer he
may have once been mortal but centuries
of killing demons had allowed him to
transcend ordinary human physiology he
did not Tire never lost strength never
needed to eat or drink and was near
enough Immortal yet among all the chaos
that was on furling a solitary
researcher had just managed to slip out
of the Doom slayer's reach he ran as
fast and far as he was physically able
the mobile task force troops were
getting eviscerated and The Slayer could
easily tear through the whole Foundation
then fleeing for his life the researcher
had an idea either a stroke of Genius or
total idiocy and a risky move either way
he would send an anomaly on the Doom
Slayer he turned to the nearest
containment cell a windowless room with
a heavy locked door hurriedly inputting
his security clearance code the
researcher heaved the door open and
covered his eyes with his arm it
wouldn't have been his first choice of
SCP to send into battle
scp-096's cell was the closest lumbering
out of its containment chamber on its
misshapen elongated legs
scp-096 scan the area alarms were
blaring it was loud and frightening to
the timid albeit terrifying creature it
reached up to cover its ears and
bewilderment not that the researcher who
at Freda could see what it was doing for
one his eyes were still covered and for
another he was already dead thanks to
the Doom Slayer barging shoulder first
through a nearby wall and raining debris
onto the nearby researcher beneath the
visor of his helmet the Marine breathed
heavily panting but not tiring as he
looked at the pale skinny creature in
the corridor before him it was clutching
the sides of its head its huge jaw hung
open as far as the Slayer knew he was
making progress his attack was working
he'd killed enough of these demonic
imposters that they were starting to
reveal their true forms although in all
his years of Bloodshed and being a
Scourge to the denizens of hell he
hadn't quite ever seen a demon that
looked like the shy guy not that it
mattered to doomguy before long it'd be
dead like all the
The Towering stick thin creature turned
to face the armor adorned Warrior and
shrieked immediately overcome with
anguish having a full-blown breakdown as
it often did whenever someone looked at
it as the demon killer stomped down the
corridor towards it the Doom blade a
long Sleek razor sharp edge extended
from the slayer's complex where it was
mounted on his wrist he reached down and
yanked the ripcord on his chainsaw too
he was long overdue for a glory kill but
before he could strike at scp-096 the
shy guy moved with impossible speed
faster than even the Doom Marine himself
it zip behind the encroaching Marine
moving quicker than he could receive one
second scp-096 was crying and wailing in
front of him the not even a full second
later the creature was towering over
doomguy from behind
scp-096 gripped the Doom blade and
snapped it with ease like breaking a
twig before reaching its other long arm
down and pulling the chainsaw from Doom
guy's hand the motorized blade was still
running as a it clattered to the ground
cutting a hole through the floor and
falling down into the lower level of the
facility enraged as he very often was
the Doom Slayer reached both arms back
behind his head and gripped the
elongated torso of scp-096 the virtually
Immortal killing machine hurled the
creature over his head with ease thanks
of course to his immense strength
doomguy could lift objects far heavier
than most ordinary humans and carry
heavy weapons without tiring he had even
grappled hand to hand with demons
throwing the shy guy down the corridor
like hurling a basketball was no trouble
for the space-faring slaughterer of
Satan's spawn screaming and Howling in
pain as cp096 crashed to the ground at
the far end of the corridor tumbling
over itself thanks to its long limbs
before landing in a confused heat as the
shy guy reoriented itself struggling
back onto its feet and standing up at
its full height it was instantly knocked
back down as the force of some Struck it
barring down on scp-096 the Doom machine
charged as signature double-barreled
sawed-off shotgun drawn he was hardly
leaving a scratch on scp-096's pale skin
despite the moderate amount of damage
the weapon was capable of two shots
would ring out reeling the creature but
not harming it then by the time scp-096
managed to recover from the blast the
Slayer had finished reloading in time to
open fire yet again even as the Doom
Slayer raced nearer closing the distance
between him and what he thought to be
another demon for him to kill the
shotgun seemed to have little effect
against the shy guy at close range
stowing the weapon doomguy put all of
his focus and energy into his charge
heavy boots stomping against the ground
as he raced towards the shy guy still
stunned by the latest shotgun blast
before the creature could steady itself
this time it was struck by another force
a heavy object barreling towards it the
Doom Slayer shoulder barged as
096 sending the pair of them crashing
through the nearest wall they burst into
a neighboring room with a doom Slayer
keeping a single armed grip around the
shy guy while repeatedly delivering
vicious punches to its gut with his
other hand not once relenting
scp-096 screeched in pain clawing at the
Slayer but unable to tear through his
impenetrable armor as they crash through
yet another wall
scp-096 did something it rarely ever did
in fact maybe something it had never
ever done before it ran away from
someone that had looked at it while the
creature was deeply insecure and so
self-conscious that it would kill anyone
who saw so much as a photograph of it it
didn't often feel afraid but the Doom
Slayer this muscle-bound killing machine
that had brutally butchered actual
demons was so imposing so threatening
and so effective at dispensing painful
punishment that he scared the fight out
of scp-096
sobbing with Terror the creature zipped
away using its anomalous speed trying
desperately to put as much distance
between it and the Doom Marine as it
possibly could but therein lay the
problem no sooner had scp-096 gotten
away from the scourge of hell then the
creature immediately felt the familiar
call whether it was an inescapable
compulsion to kill everyone who looked
at it but the fact of the Shy Guy's
biology It could only distance itself
from the Slayer for a few seconds before
it reappeared next to him from the
doomguy's perspective it seemed like the
creature was intentionally disappearing
and reappearing using its
teleportation-like speed to evade a
volley of his attacks
scp-096 came at him again stuck in a
loop of trying to attack the Doom Slayer
for looking at it to immediately
regretting that course of action and
fleeing in fear of its hulking heavy
weapon toting Target doomguy Drew every
weapon he had in his Arsenal launching a
barrage of high explosive ordinance from
rocket launcher to try and kill
scp-096 the resulting damage practically
reduced an entire wing of the foundation
site to Rubble but still couldn't kill
the slayer's opponent meanwhile in the
moments that the shine guy temporarily
forgot his own fear for the Doom guy it
managed to rush towards him swiping the
Marines various technologically advanced
armaments out of his hands before
instantly remembering why he was so
scared of the green armored force of
Destruction and dashing away doomguys
supply of weapons had all but depleted
neither he nor scp-096 were getting
tired out by their constant back and
forth they were locked in a stalemate
until the shy guy tried to get back to
its cell zipping away once again it
cowered in the corner reaching for an
old worn out paper bag that had slipped
over its head it sat down trembling
rocking back and forth in a fetal
position the shy guy was terrified an
overwhelming debilitating fear gripped
it fear that became pure dread as the
sound of heavy boots began to stomp
closer and closer kicking the steel door
off its hinges the doomslayer walked
into
scp-096's cell carrying something huge
in his hands it was one of the most
devastating weapons doomguy had at his
disposal capable of unleashing Untold
destruction The BFG 9000 without remorse
not caring that the creature seemed to
have retreated and was cowering away
from him the Slayer raised the powerful
weapon and fired an enormous ball of
green energy the blast engulfed the
entire room tendrils snaking out from
the energy projectile causing additional
damage to the surrounding area until
there was nothing left of
scp-096 now for another Showdown brought
to you through the animatron 6000 go and
check out Mandalorian vs scp-610 the
flesh that hates and could homelander's
ego crush the SCP Foundation to see a
super-powered psychopath go up against
the foundation themselves